♪ ♪
>> Laura: YOU THOUGHT ONE
PROTESTER LITERALLY TRIED TO PRY
OPEN THE 13-TON BRONZE DOORS OF
THE SUPREME COURT, AND YOU
THOUGHT WHEN ANTIFA TOOK OVER
PORTLAND, PHYSICALLY ATTACKING
CARS, THE LEFTIST VIOLENCE IS
ALSO SPILLING ONTO COLLEGE
CAMPUSES THAT WILL.
THE REPUBLICAN SON OF OBAMA
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR SUSAN
RICE SAID HE WAS ASSAULTED AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND, AN
EVENT SUPPORTING BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
HIS PARTNER THAT WITNESSED IT,
BEN ESPOSITO, IS WITH US TONIGH
TONIGHT.
BEN, TAKE US THROUGH WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> THANK YOU LAURA, GREAT TO BE
HERE.
WE HAVE THESE EVENTS REGULARLY,
CHANGE MY MIND EVENTS, WHERE WE
PROMOTE CONSERVATIVE VIEWS ON
CAMPUS THAT FRANKLY DOESN'T HAVE
A LOT OF THEM.
WE WERE STANDING UP THE OTHER
DAY FOR DUE PROCESS AND DURING
THIS EVENT, ONE OF THE
PROTESTERS WHO SHOWED UP KIND OF
GOT UPSET AT JOHN, AND SHOWED UP
AND PUSHED HIM AND HIT HIM AND
PUSHED HIM BACK.
WE EVENTUALLY HAD TO CALL THE
POLICE AND MAKE SURE EVERYTHING
GOT SETTLED DOWN.
BE ONE IT WAS A WOMAN, I
UNDERSTAND?
IS THAT RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> Laura: ARE YOU AFRAID TO
IDENTIFY HER?
>> WE'VE IDENTIFIED HER ON OUR
FACEBOOK, I DON'T THINK WE NEED
TO THROW OUR NAME OUT, HER NAME
IS MELINDA, BUT I DON'T THINK WE
NEED TO THROW HER NAME OUT TO
THE MASSES.
SHE ASSAULTED JOHN AND KNOW WE
ARE PRESSING CHARGES FOR JOHN.
>> SO YOU ARE EXERCISING
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS?
>> NOT REALLY.
IT'S KIND OF CRAZY, BECAUSE WE
DO KNOW SOME PROMINENT AND VERY
AND THIS IS -- SHE WAS UPSET AT
JOHN FOR FILMING HER RIPPING
THESE FLYERS BECAUSE WE ARE JUST
TRYING TO GET THESE DOCUMENTED.
SHE WASN'T HAPPY WITH THAT AND
SHE ATTACKED HIM FOR IT.
>> Laura: SO WAS IT -- DOES HE
FACED MORE PUSHBACK JUST BECAUSE
OF HIS FAMILY LINEAGE?
>> I THINK PERHAPS BUT I THINK
THE REASON HE PUSHES -- HAS
PUSHBACK ANYWHERE IS BECAUSE
HE'S A CONSERVATIVE ON A COLLEGE
CAMPUS PROMOTING INDIVIDUAL
LIBERTY.
THE STUDENTS ARE EXPECTED TO
CONFORM.
>> Laura: THEN, KEEP DOING
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE DOING
BECAUSE GUESS WHAT, THERE ARE A
LOT MORE STUDENTS THAT AGREE
WITH YOU AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE
FUN DOING IT AND YOU HAVE TO
KEEP DOING IT.
I WENT THROUGH THE SAME THING AT
DARTMOUTH, KEEP DOING WHAT YOU